76 of American adults aged 17 to 24
either too obese to qualify or have
other medical issues or criminal
histories that would make them
ineligible to serve in the U.S armed
forces without a waiver I wish that
number was higher I'm all about
inclusivity it bothers me when it's
inclusivity for inclusivity's purpose
and just so we can say we're inclusive I
think that the military should be very
exclusive because at the end of the day
I look at what is it that you want to do
and what are the standards for that job
what are they based off of and I can
only speak through the lens of my own
previous military experience the
standards that our job was based on and
that we were held to came from a
battlefield and I don't give about your
woke ideology because none of that
matters when you're covered with your
friends brains I think it should be
super hard to get into the military we
should exclude most people from it
because they don't meet the physical
standard the intelligence standard the
educational standards all of those
things that's a good thing I think we
are headed down the wrong path when we
just start opening the doors up and
letting all those people in because that
is not a military that is based to
operate in the environment that the
standards are based upon